>>Chris: One of the
things that I spend a lot
of time thinking about is scaling up.
We know that scaling up an education
is much more difficult than it is
in business where it's pretty easy
to have every McDonalds fry
French fries in the same way.
It's very difficult even
for a successful teacher
to move her innovation down the
hall, let alone into another school
or another district
halfway across the country.
So I've developed a five dimensional
framework for thinking about scale
and by paying attention to each of
the dimensions we can make good ideas
in education, easier to adapt
and transfer to other settings.
One of the dimensions is depth
and that just deals with the fact
that to be worth scaling, something
needs to be powerful to be attractive
to other people, something needs to
show evidence that it's succeeded
and so people who pay attention to
depth make their innovation more
and more desirable over time.
A second dimension deals with spread
and spread involves making
the innovation easier
and cheaper to adapt.
So sometimes we build a Cadillac
version that works wonderfully
but it costs a lot and then we
ask could we build something
that was 70 percent as powerful
but at 30 percent of the cost,
that's really what spread is about.
Sustainability deals with the idea
that you don't always have all the
conditions for success that you want.
Perhaps you have a
technology based innovation
but the technology only
works some of the time.
Perhaps you have an innovation
for science class but some
of the science teachers don't really
have much background in science.
Looks like some of the conditions
for success might be marginal.
Sustainability says let's go
build things that can work
under adverse conditions, hybrids if
you will that are customized to one
or another tough problem that
full innovation confronts
and those hybrids may
not work as well
as when everything is
perfect for innovating.
But they work well
enough to be worth doing,
so sustainability is
another dimension.
Shift is a dimension
that's very important
because it involves the people
that are doing the innovation
taking ownership of it.
Now they're not doing your
innovation, they have taken charge
of their innovation, they've made it
theirs, they're more likely to stay
with it, it's more likely
to work where they are
because they understand
what works in their setting.
And then evolution the final
dimension deals with shift
and when people do make a shift
and they own the innovation
and they change it, how do you as the
designer of the innovation respond
to that, do you see it as
an opportunity to think
about the whole thing differently?
Maybe to evolve in a direction
that you weren't expecting.
So we've tried applying
this framework to a number
of different projects
across education
that were really quite
different from one another.
Teacher professional development
projects, kids building games,
school districts doing one
to one initiatives and so on
and the dimensions have
held up pretty well.
There's a lots of reasons
why people aren't able
to scale things successfully and the
reasons, the traps that people fall
into also tend to map
onto this five dimensions.
On the dimension of depth, people
try to make something perfect,
so they keep trying to make it
more and more and more powerful,
oh we can add this, we can add
that, it's not ready to scale yet
and so it never scales because
it's a black hole to try
to keep improving something
indefinitely.
On the dimension of sustainability
where you're hybridizing something
to make it work under adverse
conditions sometimes you worry
because you feel as if you can't
make it work under some conditions
that it's an innovation
that doesn't work
if the teacher doesn't understand
the content or it really doesn't work
if you don't have the technology
working a hundred percent of the time
and it's okay, it's okay to build an
innovation that only works sometimes
in some places because it's still
going to be very powerful there.
Under the dimension of spread
people who worked really hard
to make something that's powerful
worry about making a light version
of it, it seems like
a perversion somehow
to make something that's
less powerful.
But if it's less powerful and it
reaches ten times as many people
as the more powerful version you're
actually having a bigger impact,
even though you may feel as
if you're not doing as well.
Shift, well people who've developed
something think of it as theirs,
they like having their brand on it,
they like it being just the
way that they developed it.
The idea that other people take it
and own it and change it, modify it,
oh it feels like I don't
know, somebody stealing this.
But in fact if you really want
something to scale you have to let go
of it and you have to let
other people in on it.
And evolution is hard because
once you've worked on something
for a long time you have a kind of
tunnel vision connected with it.
Other people change it in ways
that you weren't expecting.
You have to become flexible
mentally and go back and try
to see it with fresh eyes.
Making the familiar strange is one of
the creativity strategies and that's
at the heart of that particular trap.
So all of those traps in the sense
are emotional more than intellectual
and combined they do block a
lot of things from scaling.
My colleagues and I are working
to develop virtual performance
assessments, we know that paper
and pencil item based tests
while they're reliable,
while they're practical,
while they're inexpensive
are not very valid,
they don't really measure a lot
of the things that we care most
about students learning
21st century skills,
higher order thinking, collaboration.
So we need some kind of measures
that help us accurately determine
where we're succeeding
and where we're not
and what we're doing is using
the Alice in Wonderland interface
that underlies things like
Second Life or World of Warcraft,
where you become a digital
person in a virtual world.
To build assessments where the
student is confronted over an hour
and hour and a half with a
really interesting challenge.
The first of these that we're
building, you appear on a bay
in Alaska where the kelp are
dying and we try to figure
out what you know and don't
know about the scientific method
by how you respond in terms of going
around the bay, collecting evidence,
making inferences,
performing an experiment.
It's a much richer problem than one
can pose on a paper and pencil test
and we also collect much
more detailed information
than just making them multiple choice
selection because we're storing
at the back end all the movements
and the actions and the statements
and the data collection that the
person is doing and then mapping
that against an elaborate
definition of what the sub skills are
that constitute science inquiry.
It's not easy to aggregate too
much information into those kinds
of judgments about skills.
So it's too early to say
whether we're really going
to succeed in that.
But I think we're looking in the
right dark alley rather than trying
to look under the street
light of the item based tests
which are never going to be valid,
no matter how much effort we put
into them, they're just too
simplistic and impoverished.
So whether it's our group or whether
it's some other group I believe
that in the next five years
there will be a big breakthrough
in assessment and when that happens
for the first time we're going
to have a really powerful
way of measuring which kinds
of pedagogy are most effective
in teaching 21st century skills
and sophisticated educational
outcomes and I'm very excited
about that because I think it's going
to clearly show that active learning,
project based learning, collaborative
learning, a lot of the things
that we've known were powerful
but couldn't prove were powerful.
We're finally going to
have a microscope I hope
that lets us see that.
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org